he is with us in Colorado hi Kathy how
are you okay thank you for taking my
call appreciate it
a retiree a retired administrative
assistant aged 69 pension plan and we
have not had any coal um and we had been
promised for a few years and not sure
when we're going to get another one I
have had a couple of part-time seasonal
jobs not because I had to have them so
much just I have enjoyed them during
retirement but I will just write to the
place where some physical issues I could
kind of see the handwriting on the wall
last year on hearing visual I had quite
a few FAR's last year and just some
other well just getting to the point
it's getting harder and harder to to
work and drive especially how much is
your how much is your pension income
Kathy about 1900 a month plus you have
Social Security right
no no this is a pair of pension and WP
unfortunately I don't have anything
1,900 all month coming in and that's all
right last year and then of course with
Corona everything's dropped will my plan
and Terra Colonia had ended okay I think
this year I'm gonna
so okay and what have you been pulling
the income do you think it's worth Kathy
the last assessment we got last year it
was just over 300,000 but I would
imagine by now it's probably it probably
tax assessment is not a really an
indication of value so it sounds like
what you're going to need to do is get
with your smart Vista pro on 130 that's
invested and have the income that it is
creating whatever that is right now it's
not creating as much but you know and
you could pull off if you pulled off ten
thousand dollars a year off 130 it'll
last you a long long long long time and
that's $800 a month to supplementary
1,900 and if you sold your home because
it's creating maintenance issues and
took the 300,000 and you
and if you bought like a nice condo for
200,000 that would free you up some more
money to invest and you would get rid of
the maintenance issues simultaneously so
it sounds like you're the math is
telling you it's time to make some
changes now I wouldn't do any of that in
the next 30 days I would let all this
craziness blow by before you start
talking about selling a house but I mean
you could put it up for sale and if you
got a reasonable offer that's fine but
we're not trying to be crazy or
desperate or freaked out or panicked but
it does sound like you're gonna have to
make some moves and the math just kind
of you kind of lead you to those
decisions doesn't it Anthony it really
does and it's not even just just the
maintenance Dave I mean you look at the
utilities if she can go from a you know
I wonder how big our house is down to a
condo like you said I can save run her
light bill water bills they could really
save her some money make some major
adjustments in that area yeah